le ton est ferme joe biden n'hésite pas
à menacer directement vladimir poutine
un jour des sanctionnés personnellement
valises à rennes
le feriez vous je verrai ça si le
président américain n'a pas précisé la
nature des sanctions personnelles évoqué
plusieurs mesures économiques notamment
ont-elles été détaillées alors que les
forces russes poursuivent leur
déploiement à la frontière ukrainienne
et qu'aucune des escalades ne semble se
dessiner les etats unis se disent prêts
à frapper fort le guen je vous en ai
fini des réponses graduelle cette fois
nous allons démarrer en haut de
l'échelle de l'escaladé y rester
washington menace d'asphyxier les
banques russes en bloquant toutes
transactions en dollars et de geler les
avoirs alors que la bourse de moscou et
le rouble tank déjà dangereusement autre
menace celle d'une déconnexion force et
de la russie du système financier
international swift un réseau est
essentielle de transactions qui
isolerait moscou du reste du monde sur
la table également un embargo sur
certains composants électroniques ou
encore l'import des hydrocarbures un
secteur capital pour la russie mais
aussi pour l'europe en cas d' escalade
elle craint de se voir privé en plein
hiver du gaz russe qui représente plus
de 40% de ses besoins